sur ce plateau yann maël l'arer à
spécialistes du numérique et cofondateur
du site
ok dogues bonjour merci de l'autre avec
nous weiwei qui n'était pas en odeur de
sainteté qui revient du coup du côté de
londres alors que mike pompéo est en
déplacement
justement au royaume uni qu'est ce qui
se passe selon vous aujourd'hui entre
boris johnson et mike pompéo est ce
qu'on parle de why why et de la salle g
c'est un peu une position d'équilibriste
c'est la même chose qui est adoptée à
l'échelle l'union européenne un deal oui
mais oui et on dit oui mais aux états
unis
donc on donne raison à personne et on
donne tort aucun non plus des des
interlocuteurs et pourquoi l'idée étant
de ne pas se couper du marché américain
mais de pas non plus se froisser avec le
marché chinois qui est aujourd'hui
prépondérant
donc du coup en gagnent du temps c'est
ça on gagne du temps et puis on essaye
de trouver une position d'équilibriste
entre bas certains arguments qui peuvent
s'entendre notamment sur la protection
et la sûreté de dd des sites les plus
sensibles et notamment les sites
militaires et puis de l'autre côté
et bien on n'interdit pas tout
développement de huawei sur le
territoire européen ou anglais est ce
qui est intéressant c'est de voir qu'on
a la même que la même problématique la
même question est quasiment la même
réponse
alors que les anglais sont en train de
quitter l'europe justement est-ce que
le fait que ça intervienne maintenant
est ce que c'est une coïncidence ou pas
alors c'est une totale incidence la
question se pose partout de la même
façon dans les territoires européens et
on est en train de déployer la singer et
donc forcément les opérateurs se
demandent avec quelles technologies vont
pouvoir déployer ce nouveau réseau
mobile et on parle de conditions
strictes ça veut dire quoi exactement
alors des conditions strictes pour le
pour les anglais c'est notamment donc le
disait la limitation sur les zones
sensibles donc pas d'installation de
dentelle oui oui près par exemple d'une
centrale nucléaire puisque demain toutes
les infrastructures vont utiliser ces
réseaux 5g et si on coupait la 5g près
d'une centrale nucléaire ça vous à dire
que peut-être la centrale nucléaire
s'arrête
de la même façon si on met des antennes
5g près du gouvernement peut-être mais
je dis bien peut-être on pourrait
entendre ce que dit le gouvernement sur
sur son mobile
mais parce que washington soupçonne
d'espionnage
pour pour pékin est ce que c'est un
camouflet pour washington que londres et
que bruxelles autorise à huawei sous
condition donc de développer le réseau
singer je pense que l'europe
malheureusement n'a pas beaucoup le
choix les impôts milieu du gué entre
deux géants et elles peuvent vraiment
trouver une position d'équilibriste ce
que je disais elle doit satisfaire un
petit peu aux intérêts américains mais
pas complètement parce qu'aujourd'hui
tous les intérêts de l'europe ou des
états qui se trouve aujourd'hui son
territoire européen ne sont pas
uniquement du côté américain
est ce que ça veut dire que huawei et
hop retour noble aujourd'hui oui
incontournable notamment du point de vue
technologique parce qu'elles ont
anticipé par rapport à tous les autres
le développement de cette technologie
qui sont plus compétitifs sont moins
chers que leurs leurs concurrents leurs
homologues européens et justement leurs
homologues européens et leurs homologues
français
qu'est ce qu'ils disent est ce qui va se
passer notamment sur le sol français
alors sur le sol français j'ai vu que
ericsson allait déployer une unité de
r&d de recherche et développement sur le
territoire français donc peut-être qu'il
faudra choisir celui qui est le plus
francophone de tous nokia n'est pas
français mais sur le territoire européen
et après c'est chaque opérateur qui
choisit le réseau il préfère nokia est
par exemple préféré par free donc free
n'a pas à se poser la question de huawei
ou pas
ils ont déjà fait ce choix merci
beaucoup il ya deux mails l'erreur
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes spécialiste du
numérique et co fondateur du site au
crédoc